good morning strange sleepers welcome to
complexities of color in competing my
name is Ellen Wondra and I'm real
excited to talk with you today about
color and although weird wonderful parts
of it that we don't really think about
in our daily lives are you all having a
good weekend like you thanks for joining
me on this beautiful Saturday first good
answer did anybody actually bring any
hand work any like knitting or cross
stitching yeah all right I love it okay
oh wait hold on it helps when you
actually start your slides and then you
can click through them maybe the second
complexity of color and computing is
that sometimes you start your slideshow
wrong okay we're going to be drinking
from the fire hose a little bit in this
high-level survey on the principles of
color and kind of depending on your
starting point it might be a little bit
overwhelming my main hope is that at
least glancing some of these processes
and potential complications behind what
color is how humans perceive color
versus how machines perceive color and
some of this history will help you as
you go forward in your own technical
journey I'm also hoping to give you some
technical tips and talk about some
current use of color especially in
textiles and counteracting things like
facial recognition which just happened
to be some of my own personal interests
I do want to note at the top before we
dive in that we are going to talk about
racism a couple of times mostly in
historical context and in the context of
facial recognition this is not a talk
that is about racism but it did come up
in my research several times and as a
white woman who does benefit from
systemic racism omitting it from this
talk would be perpetuating it so I
decided to leave it in in my personal
experience understanding some of the
forces behind what makes something work
even if not everything sticks can really
help me write better more accessible
code in the future because I know why
that rule is there even I don't remember
all of the specific pieces of the puzzle
okay so a little bit about me so we have
a starting point for this whole thing
and I'm Ellen as I said at the top I'm
from Illinois originally
I'm currently based out of Tacoma
Washington I was in the inaugural class
of the ADA developers Academy which is a
code school for women and gender diverse
individuals before I was a developer I
was a crafter and I learned how to
process algorithms by going to Michael's
crafts and going to the clearance rack
and getting knitting needles and yarn
and taking the string and figuring out
how to turn it into cloth I dabble
mostly in fiber arts some of which I did
include here and lately I've been
playing a lot with cross stitch and I
created on the right let's see up above
you can see a completed cross stitch
that I created on the right and a
pattern that I generated on the left
with my stitch of firegem which is
something that you can find and github
for reference
many handwork patterns do look like this
and like locks of color or shapes
arranged in clear patterns so a few
years ago when an ex-girlfriend
challenged me to create a ruby gem that
converts pictures to cross stitch this
task seemed brilliant simple I just need
to cut Naima Jin to a grid and compare
the colors in the sections of the grid
with my available colors of thread which
I naively thought wouldn't be too hard
but in order to do that I had to learn a
lot more about color and I'm gonna pass
some of that knowledge on to you
so first what actually is color easy
it's just energy waves grouped on the
electromagnetic spectrum boom okay this
honestly reminds me of my first day in
code school when my instructor described
git as a directed a cyclical graph and
then also did a little mic drop
luckily also as a joke in nature color
starts out as white light containing all
of the colors on the electromagnetic
spectrum when this light hits objects it
bounces off of those objects and some of
those wavelengths are absorbed the
remaining still moving electromagnetic
waves continue on and they hit your eye
giving an object of color this is what
we call color subtractive the white
light contains all of the color until we
subtract certain colors to arrive at our
final color
so let's anchor this in a real-world
example let's look at these lovely
flowers that my roommate got last week
the same light light containing all of
the colors of the same groupings of the
electromagnetic wavelengths hits those
flowers but on the different flowers
absorb different wavelengths of light
the red flowers absorb most of the light
that was sent to them leaving just a
loose wavelength of red remaining to
bounce back into your eye the purple
flowers on the other hand don't absorb
much at all they absorb a couple of
wavelengths and send on a very short
wavelength of purple color onto your eye
sometimes this energy is enough to
translate to noticeable heat as well
anecdotally when I taught this lesson to
my roommate in preparation for this talk
and casually mentioned that this heat
factor does sometimes occur he was
shocked to discover that the red flowers
were in fact warmer than the purple
flowers I did mention a few times that
this light then bounces from the objects
to our eyes so how does the human eye
actually see color well once the light
enters the eye the lens at the front of
your eye focuses the beam so that it
hits the retina on the back of the eye
which is a part of the optic nerve
notably if you're near or farsighted you
may use glasses to perfect the lenses
aim like me who so that the light really
focuses on the retina instead of
focusing in front or in back of the
retina the retina then has specialized
cells called rods and cones the rods are
sensitive to light but not to color this
is why we don't see color as well in the
dark
the cones are sensitive to changes in
color these cones are themselves
specialized and each type of cone is
more sensitive to changes in red green
or blue there are exceptions of course
if there is damage or corrosion to the
optic nerve for some reason or if you
lack the gene that's required to provide
that optic nerve with the right pigments
of color you might end up partially or
completely colorblind this means that
your brain can take two completely
different wavelengths of color and
interpret them as if they're the same
weirdly this is our first four
in to racism for the day there's a
statistic that gets tossed around a lot
when you talk about being colorblind and
that statistic is 8% of men and point 5
percent of women are colorblind both the
articles usually don't tell you is that
this study was done on people with
northern European ancestry I spent a lot
of time digging around on the internet
trying to find a study that actually was
broader than the specific northern
European ancestry number and I couldn't
find it so we don't actually know how
many people are colorblind
it could be fewer than 4.25 percent of
the population but it could also be a
lot more we just don't know the data is
not there regardless though we know that
ie11 is the most popular version of
Internet Explorer currently in use and
it was only 2.6 1% of the market share
of browser clients in August of 2019
sorry the most popular IE browser is
around half as popular as being
colorblind so we should be paying
attention to these variances in color
vision when we code okay so that's the
human eye pixels work a little bit
differently however instead of a ray of
light from a third party source art from
a third party source bouncing off of an
object pixels create color by using
three tiny bulbs against a black
background each colors turned on in some
intensity between 0 and 255 these three
colors in combination make other colors
we call this additive color because the
colors created by adding light together
instead of splitting light apart
most pixels use RGB which means red
green and blue there's a couple mark in
computer color spaces that come up a lot
including srgb which is the standardized
RGB hexadecimal which is a way of
representing RGB see ymk which stands
for cyan yellow magenta and black which
you can see here to the cyan yellow
magenta and black that have been created
in the intersections of the green
red and blue which is and it's a color
subtractive method of measuring color
and HSL which stands for hue saturation
and light but for the purposes of this
talk however we're going to focus on RGB
since it's based on the physics of the
eye but it also reveals a lot of the
limitations and interesting cliffs than
our understanding
say for example in comparing the
distance between two colors okay so now
we have some pixels let's do something
with them let's say for example you're
trying to make a cross stitch pattern of
Supreme Court Justice Ruth Bader
Ginsburg done only in the colors red
blue and green because you keep
confusing RBG with RGB for the biggest
conflict for the biggest conference talk
of your life to date he found a great
picture of her online you've divided
that picture into a grid of pixels and
now you just need to determine which of
the pixels is closest to these three
colors you've got and you can make an
RBG RGB masterpiece Euclidean math to
the rescue right my initial thought here
along with the initial thought of many
an optimistic programmer is that we can
use Euclidean math so here we say that R
1 G 1 B 1 is the color value of the
pixel we're looking at say in her lovely
eyes and R 2 G 2 B 2 is the color value
of the second pixel or in this case one
of the threads I'm sewing with then the
distance squared is R 1 minus R 2
squared plus G 1 minus G 2 squared plus
B 1 minus B 2 squared so I can check the
distance between each of the colors see
which one has the shortest distance and
decide okay I should pick that color for
that pixel it turns out however that the
answer is a lot more complicated than
that the human eye is a lot more
sensitive and changes to illumination
than it is to in changes in color it's
also more sensitive to changes in dark
tones than it is to changes in light
tones originally as color scientists
were first discovering this they
attempted to weigh the RGB values and
to a mostly Euclidean algorithm XR YG z
b but it became clear that it simply was
not complex enough to reflect the way
the human eye sees color so in 1976 the
International Commission on illumination
first standardized the value of Delta e
Delta e is an alternative algorithm for
describing the distance between two
colors it has been changed several times
throughout the years as the ability to
depict color on a screen has advanced
along with their understanding of color
after the algorithm has been applied it
describes the difference between two
colors as a single number now originally
I was going to show you the formulas for
Delta e a few of them but honestly most
of the articles that explain Delta et
you don't even attempt to show them to
you they just send you a link to a
converter like they just say don't even
try to do this yourself find someone
else who's already done it
it didn't seem helpful to show these to
you just intimidating so suffice it to
say that there is an entire branch of
color science devoted to exploring why
twice as much blue does not look the
same to the human eye as twice as much
yellow this nonlinear processing of
visual information comes up again in
photography in particular which is an
issue when we're making our RGB RBG
masterpiece remember it comes up in a
concept called gamma correction since
the human eye is so much more sensitive
to the differences in shadows than it is
to the differences in light but digital
cameras default to linear storage and
prioritization of light on encoded
images with store light at a linear rate
which leads to some unattractive images
that don't pick up on detail in the
shadows that are humanized perceive and
that do pick up on details in bright
areas that are human eyes do not luckily
practically all digital photography now
uses gamma encoding which is algorithmic
encoding that defines the relationship
between a pixel and it's actual
luminosity this means that that similar
to this idea of Delta II it uses the
available modern knowledge of the eye
and the properties of the hardware
taking the picture to
adaptations in the encoding when the
picture is taken it's more efficient and
it looks a lot better to you I do want
to note here that yesterday John Austin
did a great talk called RGV - X Y Z that
went into a game of Correction in much
more detail and it did it really well so
I highly recommend that you check that
out and go back and watch that talk if
this concept interests you I know I
talked about it for one slide you went
into it in great detail so highly
recommend checking that talk out okay
now as I mentioned earlier being
colorblind is more popular than using
Internet Explorer 11 so let's talk about
some areas of accessibility and some
access background and the web content
accessibility guideline has a few
suggestions for building accessible
websites accommodating for contrast in
color the W tag extends the you know I'm
gonna take drink water for a second this
is a real barrier transition sorry y'all
I'm a weird kind of lady so sorry this
is the choice you made when you sat down
here okay now that I've taken a moment
okay the W cat extends the Americans
with Disabilities Act of 1990 so it's in
1990 the ADA is a civil rights law that
prohibits discrimination against
individuals with disabilities like me in
all areas of life so that was in the
night in 1990 the internet wasn't
available for public use until August 6
1991 and it didn't become the behemoth
capable of running or ruining our lives
until much later so it's not terribly
surprising that the a DA didn't predict
the internet I you know a year early so
enter the web content accessibility
guidelines and WK was first published in
January 1995 as part of the web
accessibility initiative of the World
Wide Web Consortium which sought to put
together some clear simple benchmarks to
make websites more accessible not only
for disabled individuals but also for
all users on unusual devices including
cellular telephones
they were updated in December 2008 when
they became the W cab 2.0 as of June
2018 w/kg point 1 became the new
recommendation though it is not yet the
adopted standard and many websites still
failed to meet these standards and the
developers who created Beyonce comm they
are currently in the middle of a
class-action lawsuit because you cannot
have through that page and the W CAD was
cited amazon.com is currently in the
middle of a class-action lawsuit because
of similar reasons and the WK decided
thereto and in June of 2019 The Times
reported that every single Democratic
candidate for president failed the
accessibility standards listed in those
guidelines every single one so the web
content accessibility guidelines touch
on many different parts of accessibility
but since we're talking about color
we're just going to talk about color and
contrast so the Mars straightforward
requirement is that color is not used as
the only visual means of conveying
information indicating in action
prompting a response or distinguishing a
visual element it's like the first
example that comes immediately to my
mind is like an input box so let's say
you have an input field and you're
expecting something serious some valid
input and instead you get something
goofy if you are not thinking about it
you might just indicate that it's
invalid input by changing the input box
so that it's red but not all users are
going to be able to tell the difference
between a red input box and the input
box that was the color that it was
initially this doesn't work for everyone
so that's why color cannot be the only
means of conveying visual information
adding additional details like say an
error message a warning icon a stripe a
heavy outline and disabling the button
some of which I've done here are great
ways to visually denote outside of color
that something is different with the
data provided regardless you just should
not have color being the only
way that you are indicating to the user
that something is wrong or incorrect or
that they should be doing something
different with that data
okay on to contrast requirements with a
couple of exceptions the wk Triple A
requirements for minimum contrast
between text and background on a page is
four point five to one now remember this
is a minimum and not a recommendation
due to all the stuff we talked about
earlier about interpreting some colors
differently than others not all of these
are going to look the same or look
equally good so you should still use
your best judgment and let's see beyond
that you can also use things like font
size shape and style to increase
readability those exceptions that I had
mentioned just a moment ago are about
things like increasing the font size
that can change the contrast
requirements so the guide itself gives
you more recommendations to make your
text more readable the wk double-a
certification requires a 7 to 1 minimum
text contrast and the w/kg 2 to 1 added
new level double-a requirements for
non-text user interface components and
graphic objects that requires that
adjacent items have a contrast ratio of
3 to 1 in order to pass this just means
that if you make a really cool logo but
it's all in a bunch of shades of blue ah
da ba da da ba da Badia then it's
probably not going to pass a
monochromatic blue no fun song logo
sounds like a great idea but again if it
is a logo and you are trying to convey
information just in one color even if
that color is blue and a silly joke then
you're trying to convey information with
color and you should not be doing that
unless you have the correct contrast
ratios ok the thing we need to remember
though because those are all the
requirements for contrast in color
that's it
that they listed the thing we need to
remember is that their hope is going to
be axes of access that we are not
thinking about we're always going to be
behind
and that has absolutely been true and
apparent in the history of color and one
great example of this is with the surely
cards so in the 1950s Kodak sold almost
all of the color film used in the United
States in 1954 as part of an agreement
to break up their monopoly they
developed a printer that's small enough
to fit in stores so this is like what
led to being able to print photos in
your Walgreens in your CVS today right
and they decide that they need a test to
help store employees decide if the
printer has the proper balance of ink or
not
so each printer also gets a negative of
a store employee named Shirley and a
copy of a card that has been printed at
HQ the stores were told that once the
printers could make Shirley look good
the printers were balanced however they
didn't think about the fact that Shirley
was a very pale skinned white woman
wearing light colored fabric on a light
background it turns out that you need a
lot more red ink in your printer if
you're printing pictures of people with
a darker skin tone or pictures with
people with a variety of skin tones in
them but because they never tested their
printers on anyone but this very pale
skinned woman they didn't think about it
they didn't think about it and they
didn't update the Shirley cards for 20
years to include people with a variety
of skin tones 20 years the 1970s so
think about that that means that for two
decades light-skinned people had access
to easy affordable photography and
printing and example cards that included
the word normal in them you can see it
right here that was normal and people
with darker skin did not all because
Kodak made some bad choices and as a
result their printers didn't have enough
red ink in them now you'd hope that
after we saw the evidence of what twenty
years of racial bias and test data can
do to your outcomes in color we would be
better at this but we can see plenty of
evidence today that we are still
ignoring the lessons of Shirley
particularly in facial recognition
software which is notoriously unreliable
according to studies put out last year
on the major facial recognition software
programs including algorithms from
Amazon IBM and Microsoft there were
extreme differences on the quality of
facial recognition matches depending on
your gender and especially your race so
he lost my spot it's like I have strong
opinions on this and then I
well white men had a near-perfect match
rate there was a near twenty percent
failure rate for dark-skinned women
which is an astronomical difference and
it's hard to tease apart how much of
this is racism but it's a lot
we know that the datasets that they're
using to test their facial recognition
software before it gets put into
production are not including enough dark
skin and not enough female faces and
beyond that some of its color science
and some of it is inclusion there are
real-world consequences to continuing
the mistakes of Shirley's day though
in 2009 HP released a printer that was
supposed to use facial recognition to
track users but as you could see in a
viral video titled HP computers are
racist it could supposedly only track
you if you have light skin in 2017 the
iPhone acts use facial recognition to
unlock phones but then it had to start
issuing refunds to Chinese customers
because their phones couldn't tell them
apart and today we use unreliable facial
recognition to enable mass incarceration
racist datasets have racist consequences
we could and should have an entire
conference on that premise alone but
like I said this is a talk about color
I'm a little pasty to be qualified to do
a deep dive here anyway and so we're
gonna move on and get back to the color
so let's talk about some of the ways
that we've used color to encode
information now there's a long and proud
history of using color and fabric to
innocuously hide information
in plain sight especially among knitters
and sometimes it was to hide access so
there was a spy during the Revolutionary
War called Molly old mama Rinker who
would sit on a hilltop and pretend to
knit and she looked innocuous enough
that folks that let her be they just
leave her alone because they figured she
was just an old lady knitting and that
allowed her to spy there's also a long
history of women in particular knitting
code into fabric so in World Wars both
World War one and World War two and
knitters living by the railroad roads
were powerful forces for the resistance
because they were able to work
innocuously knitting code and purl the
knit stitches that meant absolutely
nothing just looked like random bits of
fabric to people who didn't know the
code but then they could hand this scarf
off to someone who understood it and it
told them the movements of the opposing
troops which is astounding and amazing
to me and then today there's still
plenty of crafters following closely in
their footsteps actually knitting and
crocheting code directly and I myself as
stitch more than a few QR codes as well
but I'd like to focus more on their
spiritual descendants the
counter-surveillance wearable take
another water break thanks for hanging
okay um there's a few details to the
counter-surveillance puzzle to talk
about before the examples so first what
I'm talking about is large the ways to
counter facial recognition using color
so to understand how this works you need
to know a little bit about how most
facial recognition works so while Apple
is currently working with light or with
a depth sorry wrong way Apple is
currently working going off of off of
depths of facial depth that most of the
facial recognition was working with
light and ease a specific points on your
vase largely your t-zone which is like
here and here and then the shape of your
jawline to establish the existence of a
human face shape and then once the
software scanning for faces has
determined like hey there's enough color
points over here and this grouping that
I think looks like a face
then it hits a database of known faces
looking for a match to the mapping of
specific colorful dots and lines that
it's found so counter-surveillance
wearables largely attack one or more of
those points in the process they hide
the t-zone they reshape the jawline they
change the grouping of these
recognizable dots or they hijack the
database hit so these are a couple of my
favorite examples of hiding the t-zone
and the jawline so on the left you have
an example of CV dazzle which is a
project created by the avant-garde
artist and computer scientist Adam
Harvey he created both the set of
instructions and a full look book set of
computer camouflage carefully be
constructing the face and the t-zone he
broke down the use of enhancers using
he's against them because they attract
light to specific points on your face
and has mathematical models and
impressive and clear scans showing the
effectiveness of his carefully
thought-out methods and his years of
work and then on the right are the
members of the insane clown posse their
fans call Juggalos and juggle apps have
a distinctive makeup style of a favor
and it turns out that that makeup style
just happens to reshape the jaw and
obscure the t-zone enough to break
facial recognition as Ticketmaster found
to their chagrin when they attempted to
use facial recognition to speed up
ticketing at an Insane Clown Posse event
so there's also some more subtle takes
so using color tops a facial recognition
software however team out of Carnegie
Mellon developed some glasses that have
dots in certain areas but the humans
just kind of look like a maybe slightly
childish fashion statement but - its
software looks like a subtle remapping
of those specific dots on your face and
that can actually make the facial
recognition software think that you are
a completely different person so the
researchers were successfully able to
trick the software into thinking that an
adult male researcher on their team was
the actress Milla Jovovich
and for an even more subtle look a team
in Hong Kong is using the same
principles of remapping those specific
and identifiable dots on your face but
working outside of the visible light
spectrum so they have LED lights and
baseball caps on the bill of a baseball
cap that shine infrared lights on their
faces they update the look of their face
in ways that are easily picked up by
facial recognition cameras as facial
details but they're completely invisible
to the human eye
easily my favorite however is another
piece that comes from Adam Harvey who as
we remember he did CV dazzle in
collaboration with - labs neuro
speculative afro feminism project which
is a transmedia exploration of the lives
of black women and the roles they play
in Technology society and culture the
idea behind this piece which this is a
prototype in case you could not tell
from its saying prototype is instead of
obscuring the face and hiding which
might potentially make you more
vulnerable in human ways you know if you
have a very obvious facial obscuring
something then humans might detect that
and then you wear a pattern like this
which is cleverly designed with the
kinds of dots and shapes that we were
talking about earlier that facial
recognition software recognizes as faces
so the software sees a scarf sees
hundreds or thousands of potential faces
attempts to make hundreds or thousands
of potential matches and is overwhelmed
and it crashes just because of this
innocuous looking after a future scarf
okay so to to kind of bring some of
these pieces together though to see I'll
remember the dress the dress right here
so here's the story for anyone who
doesn't or who didn't know anything of
it beyond hey what's what color do you
see this dress so back in 2015 in
Scotland a couple was getting ready for
their wedding and the bride's mother was
looking for a dress to wear to the event
so she took
picture of the dress she liked and she
sent it to her daughter for
consideration the daughter replied that
she really liked the golden yellow one
and the mother is baffled because she
did not take a picture of a golden
yellow dress she took a picture of a
blue and black dress so a family friend
thought this is real funny
that the dress looked very different to
the two different women so she puts the
picture online and it quickly goes viral
because it turns out that according to
one study only around 28% of people see
the dresses blue and black
while 68% see it as a white and gold so
here's the real caper today four years
later we don't actually know why this
phenomenon occurs so while I was
researching the dress I read a number of
different articles that said with
certainty that they had the answer and
most of them were excited reliable but
small trends but they did not know how
to replicate this effect so most of the
studies agreed that the dress phenomenon
has something to do with the assumptions
that we make when we look at this
picture for instance some people look at
the picture and automatically assumed
that it was taken in bright sunlight
based on the light spot that you see in
the upper right corner there's some
decent evidence that if you believe that
the dress picture was taken in the Sun
you're more likely to mentally subtract
blue from the picture because sunlight
over represents blue because the sky is
blue and you know compared to
incandescent can descent light bulbs it
over represents blue so then that makes
you see the dress as white and yellow
because you're mentally taking that blue
color away from it but the truth is that
oh and there's also some correlation
between the typical light wavelength
that the viewer is exposed to so if
you're a night owl versus a morning
person you know that some that is
there's like a 4% correlation between
how likely you are to see the dress as
blue and black versus white and yellow
but the truth is that the sheer number
variety and blind
since of articles claiming that they
know the truth of the science behind the
dress is further evidence that we really
do not understand it so imagine that we
had an accessibility issue that depended
on seeing this dress as blue and black
and not white angle let's say there is a
logo that we had in this image we could
not solve it because we just don't
understand the science well enough if we
had a security vulnerability that
depended on not letting that dress ever
go white and gold we couldn't fix that
because we just don't get it we couldn't
close that loophole could a hacker in
our system put a message that looks
innocuous unless you've been exposed to
a certain wavelength that flips that
dress to blue and black maybe we don't
know we just don't understand the
science well enough we have some clues
we have a few things assumptions that
we're making that may be leading us in
the right direction
but the color science really isn't there
we just don't know enough about colors
yet we don't understand what it is that
makes it look different from some brains
and others and look I've been working on
this talk for months I've been staring
at this picture for a month knowing
without a doubt that that dress is black
and blue staring at it over and over
wishing that I could make my brain flip
and see it that way but it is still
yellowing gold in my eyes even though I
know even though I've read all that
science even though I've been cramming
my head full of it
it's wild so there's so much potential
going on here in color science and
computers a lot of it's for good the
intersection of tech and color and art
can be a vibrant fascinating and
beautiful place but we also know that it
does have the potential to hurt so be
thoughtful about your application of
color please in the world if you're
trying to communicate with color
remember that there are many ways to
perceive it which makes it so complex
but there are some
I'm out there to help you and consider
the ramifications if you're building
software that provides an experience
based on color I truly believe that we
can learn from our mistakes and be
better so go out there and make
something beautiful
[Applause]
yeah I think I have like three minutes I
could take one or two questions and yeah
in the back hi perception language oh
I've seen a little bit years and years
ago that there is sorry the question was
have I seen the research that links
color perception and language and if I
recall correctly there is some research
that that shows and correct me if I'm
wrong but there's some research that
shows that people are more likely to see
or that if they don't have a word for a
color they don't see it and then as you
increase the language for it they're
more likely to perceive it yeah I don't
as the reality is I saw that like many
years ago so I don't have a connection
to it here yeah it sounds interesting i
I literally had forgotten until you
brought it up and now I kind of want to
go check it out and see how it compares
to this but yeah thank you no that's a
good thing to bring it yeah what's up
yes I have so there are a couple so the
question was have I seen any of the
attempts out of Hong Kong to disrupt
facial recognition so a couple of
interesting ones one is of course
they're just literally pulling the
facial recognition polls down which is
effective yeah they're also using a lot
of lasers and stuff to you to disrupt
the this so what they're doing
effectively is that they're working
outside the visible light spectrum and
using lasers and like infrared and stuff
to shine it into the cameras and stuff
right if I'm correct me if I'm wrong but
I believe that's what I think that what
I from what I have seen so in Hong Kong
they they have facial recognition
cameras and they're trying to disrupt
them by shining lights and lasers at the
towers and things like that and like
because again you can work outside the
visible spectrum you can do a lot of the
potential here comes from the fact that
like the the things that you can do
uh the things that humans see and the
things that computers say you're not the
same so like working outside that
visible light spectrum they're doing a
lot of that in Hong Kong because again
they were the ones that had the the caps
that were shining lights on the face and
so they're also like using laser
pointers to shine at the the facial
recognition towers because then the
facial recognition towers can't see your
face because they're already like
undetected lasers like what there's all
this light in me you know if you are
already full of wavelengths that was a
very Babli response to that but yeah
great thanks alright and I have just
about at time thank you all for being
such a great audience I did bring some
cross-stitch examples down here if you
want to take a look and then also I have
some knotek for Ike ice posters
my only question put it somewhere where
other people can see it thank you so
much for being so great
[Applause]